- [Voiceover] We've
made some good progress
in our derivation of parts of
the Lorentz transformation.
We've been able to
express x prime in terms
of our Lorentz factor and x and v and t.
And we've been able to
switch things around
and represent x in terms
of the Lorentz factor
and x prime and v and t prime.
And we were able to solve
for the Lorentz factor.
Now, the final missing
piece in order for us
to have the full transformation
is to express t prime
in terms of x and t.
So, how can do we do that?
Well, the way I'm going to
tackle it is I'm just going
to take this equation right over here,
let me underline it.
I'm just gonna take that
equation right over there
and solve for t prime.
And the parts that have an x prime in it,
I'm gonna substitute with this.
So let's do that, let's
solve this for t prime.
The first thing that I wanna do is
I wanna divide both sides of this equation
by the Lorentz factor or by gamma.
So if I do that, I'm going to get,
I'm gonna move it over to the
left so I have more space,.
It's going to be x over gamma,
x over gamma
is equal to x prime.
x prime plus v
times t prime.
t prime, let me do it
in that same blue color.
Now everything I'm gonna do here
is pretty straightforward algebra,
but it's gonna get a little hairy,
so that's why I wanna take some caution
with the colors and progress slowly.
Now, since I wanna solve for t prime,
let me subtract x prime from both sides.
So the left-hand side is
going to be x over gamma.
I think that looks like a v too much.
x over gamma minus x prime.
Minus x prime
is equal to v times t prime.
v times t prime.
And now, to solve for t prime,
let's just divide both sides by v.
And so, we are going to get x,
let me do that white color.
We're gonna get x over,
well, now it's going to be gamma v.
So, gamma v,
v's in that orange color.
Gamma v
minus x prime
over v
is going to be equal to,
is equal to t prime.
So now we'll do what I said before.
We've solved for t prime
in terms of now gamma v,
x, and x prime, but now
we can take that x prime
and replace it with gamma
and all of this business
right over here, so let's do that.
If we take this
and substitute it in for x prime,
actually, let me swap sides too,
we are going to get t prime
is equal to x
over gamma.
Let me do the gamma in that red color.
Over gamma
times v
minus this stuff.
So we're gonna have gamma times,
it's a little bit tedious,
but we'll power through it.
x minus vt .
And if at any point you get inspired,
I encourage you to run with it.
So we just replaced x prime
with this stuff over here
and then we're gonna
have all of that over v.
So, all of that
over v.
And now what we can do, let's see.
Let's factor out a
gamma out of everything.
So we will get t prime
is equal to
gamma times,
and we're gonna have, it's
gonna get pretty hairy now.
Gamma times x
over gamma squared.
x over gamma squared, you
factor out a gamma here,
or another way to think
about gamma times x
over gamma squared is
gonna be x over gamma.
We still have that v over there.
v and then minus.
Minus.
And actually, let me just
distribute the minus sign,
the negative sign.
So, minus x over v.
Minus x over v.
x over v.
Looking forward to this
getting a little bit simpler.
And then a negative times
a negative is a positive,
so it's gonna be plus vt divided by v.
Well, that's just going to be plus t.
Plus t.
So, simplify it a little bit.
We're making some progress here.
And so that is going to be
equal to, actually, let me just,
so I don't have to keep
rewriting everything,
let me just focus on this
part right over here,
try to simplify it and
actually, even better,
let me just focus on that
part right over there.
That part, we can factor out an x.
If we factor out an x,
it is going to be equal to
x times one over gamma squared, v.
So let me write that down.
One over gamma squared, v.
Get the colors right.
Gamma squared, v.
Gamma squared, v,
and then minus one over v.
W have the minus one over v.
One over v.
Now, if we want to
subtract these two things,
and let me put the close parentheses.
If we wanna subtract these
two things, it's nice to have
a common denominator, so
let's multiply the numerator
and denominator here by gamma squared.
This is gamma squared,
gamma squared.
And so, now I'm going to focus on
this part right over here
and hopefully this will simplify nicely.
This is the same thing as
one minus gamma squared,
over gamma squared v.
Over gamma, I picked a different color.
Over gam, (chuckles) I'm having
trouble switching colors.
Over
gamma squared, v.
Now what does this simplify to?
Well, it seems like it
will be useful to have
a different way of writing,
well, let's just think
about what gamma squared is.
Gamma is this business right
over here, which we could,
if we were to square it, gamma squared.
Gamma, that looks like a v again.
Gamma squared is going
to be equal to one over
one minus v squared over c squared.
I just squared the numerator,
one squared is one.
Take the square of the square root,
you're just gonna get that.
And if I wanted to
simplify it a little bit,
I could multiply the numerator
and denominator by c squared.
And so then that's going to be equal to
c squared over, you
multiply the denominator
by c squared, you're gonna get c squared
minus v squared.
So how does that help us?
Well, this business.
One, we can write as
c squared minus v squared
over c squared minus v squared.
So, let's do that.
c squared minus v squared
over c squared minus v squared.
I just did that so it
has the same denominator
as gamma squared.
And then, we're going to
subtract gamma squared.
So we're going to subtract,
we're going to subtract c squared
over c squared minus v squared.
And it looks like this is
going to simplify nicely.
Well, let me just do one step at a time.
And we're gonna have all of that over,
gamma squared
is once again c squared
over c squared minus v squared.
And we're gonna multiply that times v.
Times, the v in that same color,
all of that times v.
Now, let's see, up here in the numerator,
I have c squared minus v
squared minus c squared.
So, what's going to happen is
this, and we have the same denominator,
so this and that are going to cancel.
And so this whole expression
is going to simplify to
negative v, and let me do
it in that same v color.
Negative v squared
over c squared minus v squared.
c squared minus v squared.
And we're dividing by this
and that's the same thing as
multiplying by the reciprocal,
so let's multiply b the reciprocal.
So, times c squared minus v squared
over c squared times v.
And we are now in the home stretch.
c squared times v.
And we could do some simplification now.
That's going to cancel with that.
And then, v squared divided by v,
you're just gonna be left
with a v right over there.
So, all of this crazy business
has simplified to a negative v,
and I'll just write it
in that orange color.
It has all simplified to negative v
over c squared.
So all of this
has simplified to
negative v over c squared
and so we're in the home stretch.
This expression, t prime,
it's going to be equal to gamma times,
let's write this t first.
So, t .
And then this expression has simplified
to negative v over c squared times x.
So we can write this as
minus v over c squared
times x.
And we're done.
We have just completed our
Lorentz transformation.
We started with this, that
we've been able to show
in the last few videos, and
we did a little bit of hairy,
carefully, did a little
bit of hairy algebra
to get this result: t
prime is equal to gamma
times t minus v over c squared times x.